we're gonna turn to employees at
meatpacking plants who are telling us
that they are worried about their health
but they cannot afford to lose their
jobs an ongoing investigation found
there are at least 14,000 coronavirus
cases tied to 181 plants in the United
States and at least 54 workers have died
our consumer investigative correspondent
and a Warner spoke to employees who say
they are in desperate need of their
paychecks including bonus money what
some are calling hazard pay and a good
morning good morning
advocates say many workers are afraid to
speak out fearing they may jeopardize
those paychecks those who did told us
that even so some improvements have been
made they still are afraid and they
don't feel safe inside the plants Oh
baby huh Maria didn't want us to show
her face or give her last name but her
stress shows through
she works in Grand Island Nebraska at
the jbs meatpacking plant where many
workers have fallen ill from coronavirus
on April 28th one of them died her close
friend 61 year old Reinaldo Ramirez
Betty said him he said good partner good
man he dies Ryan Brown works there too
what is it like for you in your job in
terms of a line how close are you to
other people we are very we're pretty
snug there are some places where you are
literally like shoulder to shoulder with
somebody some 3,600 people work at the
jbs plant which processes 1 billion
pounds of beef each year the company
says it's doing everything it can to
provide a safe working environment still
emails we obtained from the Regional
Health Department show at the end of
March a local emergency room doctor
called the plant a hotspot another wrote
jbs should shut down for two weeks that
never happened
by April 21st the Health Department
reported more than 230 jbs related cases
on its website jbs cites measures taken
to protect workers including temperature
checks and face masks along with
increased sanitation and physical
distances
but Brown says sometimes there's no real
feasible way to keep us all six feet
apart it's just a lot of people in one
space you know what I mean it's just
very congested to limit that congestion
jbs and producers like Tyson Foods are
taking other steps this Tyson video
shows improvements including workstation
dividers on-site medical screenings and
social distancing Meatpacking companies
have also increased pay for workers
during the crisis
Tyson announced two five hundred dollar
bonuses in May and July jbs has raised
hourly pay and is giving a six hundred
dollar bonus to workers who had no more
than two unexcused absences between
April 20th and May 15th but Mark Peron
president of the UFCW International
Union which represents many workers is
skeptical they want people to come to
work so they're paying them more money
the problem inside the plant jbs workers
who stay home because they fear
contracting the virus won't lose their
jobs the company says but they also will
not be paid which Peron says leaves many
workers with no option but to work
because they need their paychecks
doesn't necessarily mean you're
expendable and I think that people has
started to think about these workers
especially in these packing houses is
being expendable but George Washington
University expert Melissa Perry says
keeping workers safe protects the
meatpacking business as well I think
it's the economy
to frame it as though it's a choice
between workers or our meat that's
really not the issue the issue is it's a
choice between insuring city protections
within meat processing plants so that we
can continue to have a steady reliable
supply of meat back at jbs Ryan Brown is
making four dollars more per hour now
but says money isn't the answer where
you're putting people's families like a
risk and like their lives at risk I
don't think that there's you can put a
number on that on its website jbs says
it is encouraging sick team members to
stay home from
work and it is relaxed its attendance
policies they also pointed out that no
one has asked them to close the plant
local health officials say that's
because they couldn't get support from
state officials to do that we reached
out to the governor's office but never
heard back Dale thank you and I'm struck
by Ryan Browns words nobody wants to be
snug during this pandemic and you cannot
put a price on your life thank you very
much